vedi tutte queste case una volta qua era
tutta campagna
pss non dire a nessuno che te li ho dati
quando ero giovane io c'era un solo televisore per tutto il paese
adesso ce ne sono almeno tre o quattro per ogni casa
come si apre qua sto coso pronto
pronto non ti sento
pronto pronto non ti sento
cosa hai detto? ha chiamato la mamma
non ho capito! ha
chiamato la mamma
ascolta dimmelo da questo orecchio che di qua non ci sento
divertiti finché
sei giovane ascolta la nonna
quella di una volta era bella musica quella di adesso mi pare rumore non si puó sentire ma che porcheria é?
come non hai mangiato a
nonna in che senso?
alla tua eta' saltavo i fossi per il lungo
alla tua età io già
mi cucivo a macchina tutti i vestiti
altro che fashion week quella era la moda
perché adesso sono anziano ma quando ero
giovane
quante ne ho fatto erano tutte
innamorate di me
ma se non hai mangiato
niente prendine ancora un po
eh cara mio quando c'era il Duce bei tempi!
we giovane
con la tessera rover 60 io il tram non lo pago
quando ero giovane...
secondo me sei troppo magra fattelo di
voi giovani d'oggi non avete rispetto per gli anziani
non mi ricordo se ho preso la
pastiglia
no giovanna ma tu non sai chi è morto!
Carmela me la pastiglia l'ho presa?
secondo me sei troppo bianca
adesso dico a tua madre di portarti dal
dottore perché secondo me se anche un po anemica
devo andare a prendere la
pastiglia
alla tua etá mi facevo 400 chilometri in bicicletta solo per andare a trovare tua nonna
va che male al ginocchio
domani o piove o nevica
tesó guarda che bella sciarpa t'ha fatto nonna
questa col freddo che ce sta ora te serve tieni
che cos'è sto affare qua? cosa é? a cosa serve?
nonno per contattare i miei
amici eh quando io avevo la tua età e se
volevo dire una cosa un mio amico andavo
a casa sua eh
non so se te l'ho detto ma io facevo 400
chilometri tutti i giorni in bicicletta
per andare a trovare sai chi? la nonna brava
che sta a suona? ah il telefono aspetta come
funziona qua pronto non te sento ma chi
è vedi un po se riesci a parlarce te
fanno troppi reclam non si può vedere il
telegiornale in santa pace troppa pubblicità
ai miei tempi
ai miei tempi con duemila lire andavamo
al cinema e una volta usciti ci
compravamo pure il gelato
vado in bagno e arrivo subito eh
aspettame qua
alla tua età io ero già sposata e con quattro
figli ma nonna papà é figlio unico
vuoi saperne piú te di tua nonna?
sentite un po visto che mi state
parecchio simpatici eh se questo video
arriverà a 70.000 mi piace gireremo la
seconda parte se lo volete vedere
mettete mi piace iscrivetevi al canale
e attivate la campanella sennò le
notifiche non vi arrivano e non dimenticatevi di seguirmi su tutti gli altri social che
sono Instagram TikTok e Facebook mi
raccomando eh bamboloni vi mando un bacione
e TOP ADORO!